[Music]
this week's vegas drives takes us to
spring mountain ranch las vegas now's
jillian lopez shows us the hidden gem
that is super summer theater a picnic
dinner theater experience under the
stars take a look
[Music]
well today's adventure takes us inside
the beautiful mountains of spring
mountain ranch and we are just about 45
minutes outside of las vegas going to
check out the super summer theater it
happens every summer out here but first
we have to unload the car so let's get
to it
[Music]
well i have my cart of things i'm ready
to get set up to see the show but before
we do that we are hanging out with lisa
who has been a part of super summer
theater for a while now and he said this
is one of my favorite places i'm excited
to share it with everybody for but for
people who haven't been here how would
you describe the experience out here
it's an amazing experience i've been
involved for about 25 years and i
remember the first time i came out here
somebody had given me tickets and i saw
a little shop of horrors and i've been
coming out every year since you don't
realize that we're only about 20 25
minutes out of town
but you feel like you just got
transformed somewhere else
and you get out here and you just go
spring mountain ranch was the first
working ranch in las vegas and still
remains one but has also been
transformed into a theater experience
under the stars
i describe it to people who don't know
about this as a picnic dinner theater
and then i just go from there then i
tell them bring their
picnic and then when the sun goes down
the stage door goes up and we have our
our show that's right you pack up your
picnic or buy concessions on site
purchase show tickets online and
experience a super summer theater
production all these producers have been
waiting two years to put these amazing
shows on so we're very excited about
that each show runs for about three
weeks four nights a week three different
shows a summer with a lot of prep
involved normally it will take about
say four months from casting to actually
producing the show to actually what you
see right now
but there's also probably about a year
when you actually start doing the set
design doing costumes doing uh the music
in your band together so
a year four months it's about a year's
worth of producing also a lot of
behind-the-scenes work comes solely from
gracious volunteers i don't think people
realize that it's
it's a bunch of volunteer board members
providing their time as well as all of
these volunteers in the community
providing their time
and then those people on the stage
who are also
community performers superstars both on
and off the stage this is the best kept
secret in southern nevada